it's a big thing today a lot of fans are
very upset about the V TV event last
night and I'm one of them boo this
season was more disappointing than
anything ever it was the worst the worst
brother barf all right well obviously we
have a superfan here who was very
disappointed with the final season of
Game of Thrones Game of Thrones what's
that hey I'm speaking of the greatest
show ever
whoa burgers you're talking about the
show wall burgers
wait the reality show about Mark
Wahlberg's family owning and operating a
chain of burger joints that's the show
you're talking about yes it is one and
the same wall burgers is the best show
on television at least it was for its
first nine seasons 9c zarnitz seasons of
law burgers is 1,000 seasons too few but
[Applause]
season 10 of war burgers has been to put
it mildly a soul-crushing ly massive
disappointment of apocalyptically helis
proportions times infinity plus infinity
multiplied by forever all right all
right sounds to me like you really hate
the current season of Wahlburgers yes
the quality of the show's writing has
gone completely downhill and that's why
I've started this petition to rewrite
the entire tenth season of Wahlburgers
it already has over 10,000 signatures
wait a minute push in there let's see
that all you did you just wrote the word
signature
ten thousand times over ten thousand now
look I don't know this show that well
but you that show can't be that bad
oh I'll prove it's terrible with this
clip roulette I know how you feel about
going to retail I think we have a number
of products and going with a very
specific approach there is something to
be said about being able to provide the
Wahlburgers experience in somebody's
home I only care about the beef let me
get through this my brain is very small
okay alright well based on that clip I
see your point that that was that was
terrible I think they made a huge
mistake when they stopped adapting the
novels novels
well burgers it's a reality show oh it's
a reality show based on the incredibly
popular series the burgers of walls by
Mark RR Wahlberg you've got the first
book beef quest spoiler alert they find
the beef then you've got mustard storm
mustard is coming Conan B where the
yellow walkers
and then finally triumph of the pickle
just curious what's what's that one
about war and incest but season 10 of
war burgers has done nothing to capture
the magic of these books well that's
what happens when superfans get too
invested in a show they're always
disappointed I'm not some crazy superfan
Conan now would you like to read some of
my wall burgers fan fiction no I really
don't know thank you
there it is I made copies what did you
do we're gonna we're gonna act out a
scene wait wait why are we hippie why
are we doing this well Leslie asked me
to and I said yes wait a minute your
name is Leslie I guess so okay you two
move on to the kitchen set that andy
built come on you'll be playing silver
screen meets throb Mark Wahlberg and
Andy you'll be playing his brother Paul
the chef don't forget your Boston
accents and scene okay oh hi there I'm
Mark Wahlberg your brother I'm a movie
star just finished shooting one of those
movies about a robot that turns into a
car genius I'm Grillin Baggins and I
love you like a brother mark yeah we are
brothers that's right I forgot my brain
is small
even though you'll brain is smile and
yeah brother we should we should be
lovers yes lovers do it I'm Donnie
Wahlberg oh my god what is going on he's
taught you shove him out the window and
dead and we our love is forever and
scene
yes that's how you honor the our our
wahlburgers visual wait I'm sorry that
was terrible
yo we'll go hey wait a minute one last
thing Leslie you're not a Game of
Thrones fans why are you dressed like
that
oh this this is what I wear to sex
parties to the sex party
you